le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'est l'une des revendications des gilet
jaune l'objectif redonner la parole au
peuple et surtout simplifier le
référendum d'initiative populaire qui
existe déjà en france
en voici le principe un cinquième des
parlementaires soit au moins 184 députés
ou sénateurs déposerait une proposition
de loi
non seulement le conseil constitutionnel
devrait valider le texte
mais surtout le dernier préalable le
plus difficile avant le vrai référendum
rassemblé 1 10e des électeurs 4 millions
et demi de citoyens une procédure
stricte qui n'a jamais été utilisée
alors pour donner leur avis les français
ont le moyen de participer à des
consultations populaires principalement
au niveau local et dans la majorité des
cas à l'initiative des institutions en
1976 par exemple une consultation avait
lieu sur l'implantation d'une centrale
nucléaire en gironde en fait la
consultation est allé sur les deux jours
de samedi et de dimanche a pour but de
faire connaître l'opinion de la
population de ces cantons à la
différence du référendum qui valide un
projet si le oui l'emporté la
consultation locale là comme son nom l
indique qu'une valeur consultative
autre exemple en 1981 la mairie de
vertaizon dans le puy de dôme
s'inquiétait des conditions de vie de
ses administrés
une consultation était alors lancée
auprès de la population pour y apporter
des améliorations
nous avons toujours eu le souci
d'associer les jeunes à la gestion de
notre commune depuis 2004
en plus des communes toutes les
collectivités territoriales peuvent
désormais organiser des consultations
populaires et la procédure peut être
aussi à l'initiative des lecteurs ou
d'associations ici en 2010 l'une d'entre
elles
initié en votes sur l'installation d'une
ligne à grande vitesse ce vote a tout
d'un réel scrutin listes électorales
récupérer auprès de la mairie et secret
des urnes en 2016 un projet d'envergure
était aussi soumis à une consultation
populaire
l'état a invité les habitants de
loire-atlantique à s'exprimer sur le
projet d'aéroport de notre dame des
landes
le oui l'emportait mais le projet fut
malgré tout abandonné par le
gouvernement
[Musique]